eleven years ago justice with judge
jeanine began
hosted by a former prosecutor judge and
d.a
sitting not in a courtroom with armed
deputies but instead in a studio armed
with teleprompters monitors and a
dedicated staff and crew
the mission was a familiar one finding
truth and justice the jury bigger though
in fact a national one thus bringing you
truth justice and the american way
each and every week we watched events
unfold in america together through the
lens of this studio
when we started this journey we were all
a bit younger
but not as wise as we are now
we were certainly more optimistic
together we watched america though as
she went through times that were
unexpected
we watched it all together
you listened to my opens and got fired
up
you watched street justice and had a few
laughs
we interviewed those high up in the
political world the president a vice
president a prime minister
and we both laughed and got fired up
we realized that things were not as they
should be and we needed to take a stand
my opens were intended to give you the
evidence so that you as a jury would
come back with your own verdict
like me most of you drew a line in the
sand to fight for the america that we
wanted to keep the values and the
principles that our founding fathers had
defined
during that time we lost loved ones
your generosity your consolations
meant so much to me
during the tough times that i
experienced over the years
i felt the connection that we had
and so did the ratings
i thank you for fighting for me and you
know who you are
and so as we reach the end of this
journey don't think you're getting rid
of me just yet
i'll be going to the number one show on
all of cable news this monday the five
right here on fox so you'll be able to
see me five days a week
and i will continue to fight for all of
you
to make my views known
to make my arguments clear and to fight
for the america that we all know and
love
and i'll be sitting there looking out
for you as always and hopefully you'll
be right there looking back at me
and that's my open hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else